[Music]
sorry everybody we're sorry we were
putting on a clinic man we were a
nunchuck nunchuck clinic not chucking
the out of this boy how old and fat
am I I'm out of breath from nunn
chucking in place
[Music]
I stand here before you Jason Michael
oakerson survivor of what was just a
tragedy tragedy I think there's a
traumatic event it is traumatic event it
could have been a tragedy this show
would have been way weirder and darker
it's the bonfire it's maybe a somber
bonfire you know what it is it's a
reflective bonfire it's still Comedy
Central radio sirius XM 95 mm-hmm I'm
Jay oakerson drew that that survivor is
Dan Soder strength determination will
love of life really is what pulled me
through it really is and in a situation
like that you look around you go I might
have to take a life in order to keep my
life I thought I was gonna have to we
Came desperately close to eating people
as we were stuck in an elevator not 20
minutes ago
here's doctor an elevator and might I
add before you go anywhere else yeah I
just keep going I'm sorry I interrupted
we're trapped in an elevator on the one
foot from being on the ground floor of
this building and one foot away we
didn't know that 12 inches elevator
stopped we thought was on the ground but
I did a weird we bounced a little bit
which no one was well also you did a
knock on the back wall of the elevator
joking with me right before it happened
it was a timing on that for real for
real it was like crazy you were like you
think I Fonz he'd the thing off I think
you walk around punching jukeboxes
entire time we were in and trapped in an
elevator on the ground floor one foot
from the ground floor and I know that
because when it finally when it finally
opened up - I'm gonna stay up - four
minutes later we had to step down I
heard it was six a foot marina for six
minutes they tell the tale that it was
six really six minutes sounds about
right
it felt like four cuz all I can tell you
is in my upcoming biography Dan Soder
metal walls you'll be able to ID tail
minute by minute
the subtitle there is no escape going
down the Dan Soder story here's a me and
Dan never processed happening when we
were like hey let's make every elevator
ride interesting by stirring up stories
and saying fake things and trying to
make people uncomfortable and by us he
means you
and by that I mean me yeah and I will
say I will laugh along milliseconds
after my belief was that in milliseconds
the door was about to open somebody
didn't get into the elevator last minute
and I waited the entire Express part of
the of the thing we do a fun thing
because we're fun we have run here we
have a lot of fun here when we're going
down in the elevator if it opens up and
it's a full elevator and someone walks
away we always go come on
yeah come on this guy immediately makes
fun of him for looking like a vamp well
the girl wouldn't get no that's what
that is what I'm just gonna say what
happened was the last floor mmm Russell
yeah before it went Express a girl
didn't get on and when we started doing
like - come on come on she didn't get on
the door closed because the guy that was
right in front of our elevator just like
you know he had a crew-cut and his
jacket collar was flipped up of his suit
jacket his bald and no okay and his uh
and his like overcoat collar was popped
also detective vampire yeah maybe but I
said I'm on the club as soon as I
thought we we went down and right when
it stopped without thinking that it was
like bouncing even yet yeah I went that
girl to get on we shouldn't live with
our vampire Prince and I'm like now this
guy's gonna be out of my life and then
we were trapped on an elevator for six
minutes from that moment on the girl
that's discomfort Cory and Lynn both
biting lip not to laugh let me tell you
what I love about big Jay he will go
shoulder in on a joke cuz the second we
realized we were stuck Jay goes can you
use your daywalker powers to open I did
asked him if he could use his daywalker
powers to open even try by the he didn't
so I was in the front dude I would have
already had a finger
two fingers in job I'm pretty sure it's
what a woman did to get us out I'm
pretty sure I mean yeah we did it opened
up and it was a woman in cargo pants
you look like the I'll tell you what at
six if it was six minutes we were in
there and we were in contact pretty much
from about 40 seconds to a minute in
yeah at minute 550 we were told push the
door open button like we covered them I
tell you something we gave that a world
I learned about black Lou is that he's
got impatient white lady energy when
he's stuck on an elevator he's like okay
well well we've been waiting for a while
like that tone I'll tell you what
weirded me out even more sitting in
front of me standing in front of me was
a beautiful black woman and when the
thing got stuck black blue and her I
didn't know each other oh yeah you don't
know each other just started in just
engaging just and it was a she she gave
it to Lou first she was like how are you
he's like good Harry and they start just
having a little sort of back and forth
like they were having an eye contact
being like if it goes Lord of the Flies
in here yeah we know me and you got to
use our extra ankle bones to win
this battle we're gonna walk on to the
out of these white folks
I'll elevate a race war I mean that
should be a web series yeah in a stuck
elevator race Wars I'm Swedish so I'm
passive I'll be here in a quarter yeah
Oh turn around so many ideas for a stuck
elevator once we were in it though we
said Dan said you were gonna go stand in
the corner like Blair Witch yeah why is
that never acknowledged why is the big
guy doing that this makes me upset or if
you want any one of us should just win
against the back walls are like banging
our head against the wall like I got
bird but whatever bird boxes I got bird
box thing like a bird box oh look at me
a bird box think that you can I give you
your Christmas gift yeah you're not
settled down from is there something
that's gonna help me they're stuck in
elevators that true yes what are the
odds of that pretty good all right let
me see I'll tell you what that has
multiple uses hell yeah and one of them
is getting out of elevators
does it also service something I can
kill a vampire with for making fun of
him before I open the elevator let's say
a vampire sentry mean the elevator door
is it a cloak with the Cape but he has a
something that way didn't I tell you
something I saw in an airport recently a
guy wearing the overcoat with the cape
attachment not like ironically like
Hughes the guy really so I feel about
you wearing fingerless gloves dude I
love a post-apocalyptic flare just not
most buk elliptic that's like he's
Sherlock Holmes I don't know if he's
solving stuff that's like crossbow is
like the most high-tech weapon I think
you said van health as a van Helsing
jacket with you don't talk about the
Cape attached to an overcoat yeah it's a
half cape yes it's the Duster but it's
definitely a bigger case it's warm
clothes you you really think I'm gonna
go against a duster brethren like the
Cape now that's that that's the Duster
don't go to the Duster find the actual
like a cape jacket do overcoat with cape
it was there I saw one there but that
was a duster let me see
where's one with a wonderful cape right
the guy with the Inspector hat on it's
perfect oh it doesn't have a cape on it
their box is like a real son of a bitch
almost yeah we'll never turn my back on
a duster you still have your duster all
right yeah yeah dude even that
duster life check my Instagram I wore at
playing Red Dead oh I finished
loved it dude yep
pretty good I'm in the epilogue come on
you son of a bitch what's inside that
box would it be something would help you
open that box how about that mr. wise
that seems like something I can kill a
vampire and open an elevator door with
and I couldn't open a box with it
I don't think this is a few man job
misses you guys are embarrassing
yourselves at this point this better be
one hell of a present yeah what is it
architectural is it the layout of them
all you're building on the weekend
you're gonna push this thing through man
we're gonna prove I'm not gonna lie and
he says there's no veto power so once
this thing is through write a check
zoning laws moaning hogs man okay yeah
now take it over perfect thank you black
blue black blue coming in here opening
it like a man that isn't distracted nope
show anybody you got me a bubble tape I
got you a whole box of bubble tape of
bubble tea I know you do oh yeah don't
don't know yeah just I get it okay -
vampire with that you go in the box and
pull it out okay now there's four things
in here it's heavy are they all for me
yeah all for things but I hope you share
some of them okay first is it's got a
nice heavy handle on it yeah
oh wait a second you goddamn right since
we're tractable bo staff a bus
shut your mouth heavy-duty dude that's
intractable boasting yeah
real deal real real this might be
a life game change I might not be here
tomorrow
this isn't practice Christine I'll
crack his in half feel the
feel the heft on that right there yeah
Christine just got real and I got some
training I got some training your things
new chucks yeah dude but by the way
there are foam so we could beat the
out of each other
you got damn right we can look at that
Oh who's more purple I don't know but
look I think we can do a bonfire
fight with one person call in it you
know he can practice nunchucks
did what army and then are we team red
or team blue you're my team oh yeah you
probably think I was gonna put Christine
on my team but now I'm gonna nunchuck
her also by the way keep going in the
box cuz there is a you're gonna whack
we laugh so hard you're so big you just
got brain
check the box because I also got you a
bo staff carrying case yeah yeah so now
you can wear it on you keep this on me
yeah oh no is it not in there
karate because I also got you a bunch of
needles why they're used yeah by some
pretty shady folks so I wouldn't yeah
bubble wrap bubble wrap it up I noticed
people are home aiding it yeah all right
you guys got to read the directions
you said it won't retract no well yes
taste blood first I've already told you
this let me see one of those practice
nunchucks buddy see it dance with it
live it get to know it yes great
oh man my night is made I don't need
plans what the we had these when
they opened up the elevator on us if we
were holding on you're looking would
this elevator
Oh under the light your ass up Oh what
do you got a gun walk those oh
you're so lucky Dan Soder I'm your
Bumble date
well if you think this isn't the way I'm
walking around I hope our guests ready
to be super intimidation flag girl is
retracted here giving back to a master
dude look at that post F that's
badass
it's so heavy it looks like a giant
dentist equipments man you got me that
hatchet and I was like I can't not get J
or retractable real Bilbo's down what's
wrong what's you guys don't know dad
hold this
I trust you with your weapons God man
that's awesome yeah right now go in the
fishbowl really freak him out
it ain't practice no more he goes look
at Jane with his fingerless gloves
wallet chain and is that now a bo staff
holster dude do you realize the Jacob hi
you haven't been in the studio yeah
doesn't even know about our heroine tail
oh oh Jesus Christ did the reason I gave
you the bo staff that was Jay's
Christmas gift a retractable staff with
this we were trapped in an elevator
Jacob you got a question about it any
questions with the most there we were
all on it and there was a vampire there
is so much there was a vampire there was
an ebony love story there was an ebony
love story it was like Lady
Marmalade know what was a clue got his
groove back
on the elevator
yeah there was a loser tall drink of
water when you're the only black guy for
a black woman on an elephant there was a
woman that was in the front that really
what at first I thought just disliked us
I was like this this girl just doesn't
like us and then Jay pointed out she was
stressed out because I mean Lou you said
it your class get on Mike real quick you
said your cost of claustrophobic right
so like when that elevator stopped it
was a little terrified yeah yeah yeah
plus I've had some bad experiences what
elevator so you really yeah well I found
out a couple people do I think it might
be an elevator day on the bonfire but
you know now if we had weapons yeah he
was going to the DMV and didn't realize
that the Klan had offices in the sixth
floor CMBS on the eighth floor so he
hated that yeah I don't like that I
don't like that look what that's what I
mean that's the Cape a guy was wearing
that not I don't cosign that in the
Duster family yeah I mean what on
Twitter is it appropriate for lantern
shopping nannying in the 20s possibly
solving a murder
you definitely solve a murder like a
Sleepy Hollow type murder in the home
yeah caroling you could definitely go
caroling in that for sure huh but when
you go home you molest those kids oh
yeah there's some weird sort of uh
underwear wearing yeah yeah flap on flap
ass underwear people asked for a butt
flap and I just got Sal one-piece
pajamas that have a butt flap really has
you used the butt flap I don't I'm gonna
ask him out I don't even wanna know the
answer there's not a chance in
the world ever I would through a
botfly here's my question
do you fruit bowl the butt flap so you
put your underwear actually on the
bridge of your dick so your whole butt
and bits and berries are all exposed
paint the picture again you have your
butt flap right your butt flaps open and
pull the butt flap to the front
everything to hold your underwear up to
I wasn't even batting around underwear
being involved there's no wonder where
you can't wear underwear in those things
no underwear yeah so do you pull them up
you probably you do that that's the only
way you'd have to do it she just bamboo
your baboon in it yeah now here's the
problem
how about yeah how about when you want
to wipe do you wipe only one hand always
you spread a cheek with the other hand
no you you open and get in I
don't open that's a weird way that's
heavy oh yeah finger in a wedgie
I go sigh I've hold a ass cheek
and pull back like I'm a stripper I use
the I use the grip of the toilet seat so
when I lean you know and I'm like bent
my the toilet seats group of my but
enough that it's split up I get in there
here's what I've done at this point yeah
other cells I spread I spread my butt
cheeks right away okay I used to do this
a lot
yes I used to do this a lot harder I
don't do it Minister Louis J Gomez idea
I felt like an idiot because he just
does everything with Louis is too
extreme he did it too extreme and I'll
tell you what though he's not wrong
totally though and that is to spread
your butt cheeks before you sit down we
there's a lot of women in here spread
your butt cheeks before you sit down so
the seat kind of hold your butt cheeks
open so it gives a flush or surface so
shit's not going through the whole eye
and your butt cheeks even it out I know
I don't mind that idea but I used to
really stretch it hard I mean cuz you
gotta remember well it's like when you
gotta take cookies out of the oven
before they're done cooking because they
still continue to cook a little bit yes
saying that you have to pull your butt
cheeks apart a little bit cuz when you
lock them onto the seat the seats gonna
pull them open a little bit yeah I've
done it where I've gotten like you know
got a cap chapped lip uh your
sores on my ass crack your butthole
looks like the face of an eight year old
yeah um mom says my ass was looking in
our Gmail yeah oh dude this kid Scott
that I went to after school program with
used to get the most epic chapped lips
do you remember when mother got
really bad chapped lips when you were a
young boy sucking two rinds of snot head
dude
it's cry just remember laughing
and that being like Scott stop licking
your lips he's like
so yeah you're we were locked on an
elevator and got really what was I
just saying we were talking yeah it was
a street yeah but no but I was telling
you about taking a yeah
spreading the butt cheeks going down
like that I don't do that he my still
spread the butt cheeks but I used to
stand up which defeats the whole purpose
of the spread in the butt cheeks well
you're slapping it I stand up and then
start wiping my butt and it took forever
now what I do you lay on your face I did
change you said but you're now you're
saying - just like our cup on the seat
what I do is my butt cheeks already open
so I go really forward oh my got or so -
leg Hannah ball it and I bring the whole
butt up a little bit
yeah then reach behind and wipe like
that but I mean you're getting yourself
the other hand is holding this butt
cheek open I'm a right hand wiper the
left hand though is holding the other
butt cheek open you're using the force
of the seat to hold your butt cheek up
yeah I'd won that's gonna cause nerve
problems in your backside do you think
so sciatica I do think so yeah I don't
know
I lean heavy on my left side so I start
leaning on my right even it up I need
for a while yeah take rotate the tires
all right rotate my wipe just rotate
your tires up I'll rotate my wife no
problem that what's that Christine are
you're saying you bring your legs in
[Laughter]
cool you be cool okay I can't have you
doing dirt on camera with some weapons
that I got you for your birthday I
almost took Christine in the house right
there I know you did but I want you I
want you to look right now some better
voice you brought me nunchucks and I
gotta live with that voice I like
talking got me nunchucks dude I
like holding them both talking to Jay
but now look how she looks to you is it
respect or fear
sensual I can't believe I almost put
this boasting through that we've really
a downplayed how much I just whaled that
TV
give me a 12 pound retractable postive
which by the way should have had a
carrying case karate calm what's the
name of it was the box
karate mania you said karate meaning
that come then you'll know exactly what
I got you said don't look at the box cuz
you'll know what it is I go up strangle
boxes karate mania would tell you what
it is yeah it would karate Mart yeah
karate marcom for all your karate needs
yeah it's karate Mart he does fine you
never stop shop for all things all your
karate needs are you a man boy have you
thought to yourself
I'd love to kick more with my shins know
where you get shin guards for that well
we're the one weird place that has them
do you have a thing that your first
serious girlfriend will definitely throw
away do you want a person made of
sandbag to fight yes so bad I want an
angry Bob yeah or an angry mark I mean
this is right do you know this means
though in some weird way is we have to
now purchase for the people that don't
have like all their we have to purchase
a real version of all their weapons yes
we have to make a clue is gonna get a
battle-axe I think we're just gonna have
to get DJ Lou like next shackles or
something okay we'll get we'll get Lou
its key something sweet
I'm gonna get like a junkyard dog next
shackles never junkyard love junkyard
dog big thump on his butt yeah you wanna
be a junkyard dog zombie jyd sure hump
and dude we'll get you samurai swords
I'll trust you as a zombie yeah zombie
samurai swords yeah Jacobs blades he's
already got a million nine yeah but wait
till you see the ones we get yeah it's
gonna be this it's gonna be a saws your
torts gonna be a two-hander yeah keep
the murder machete upstairs and I'm
pretty sure it would not be hard to find
Lou a battle ax
but I think you find a battle exporter
that's pretty easy flag girl where after
that designed yeah that's gonna be
custom Jacob what kind of knives would
you want you are a blade specialist and
your blades were taught and if in the
future apocalypse you know we were just
reminded that it could all go down at
any time Jacob we were thinking about
restarting society in that elevator
that's what we're gonna choose and that
elevator no no but I just know I thought
that was you guys banding together in
case the shift in case went Belko
experiment that
I was I'm trying to think back on the
elevator oh how great you would have
been if you had a nunchucks no I was
thinking about who I would breed with on
that elevator cuz you and Christine are
locked up black I just got a go
Christine in this new society yes Jay
you guys walked into it together you
know it's really Bowman Christine right
now she was gonna pick you Dan she was
gonna pick you too yes you are you just
trying to make it awkward she was I
limited your choices you can I apologize
we think Christine's ugly that's
up up because you what leaders do
Christine Christy Hayes and
starters do you know I'll breeze with
you an elevator last night instigating
Jay Jay throws shade throw some shine oh
dude there it is oh yeah Becky on last
night was not happy with the girl that
hated us
I would girl that hated us I would try
to start a world with because I kind of
like that too oh yeah yeah yeah you
liked it she looked high-society if you
had your bo staff in the elevator and we
did after restart society you would be
the king so you would set the laws have
the weapon if I'm hatchet on me well
then it comes in a go she'll never get
close to me with that hatchet excuse me
you'll have to understand that's all
I'll do is be close to you you'll never
get close me as I back away yeah your
bones you thought you're gonna say hack
away at my bo staff not realizing you
got me for some reason uh industrial
quality
I was like is this real oh man that
is where's your single shot let's do our
single shots this one stop smiling yeah
these are dead serious
in this case yeah bend your arms a
little bit now bend the actual nunchucks
I mean down tilt them to yes yes that's
good you with you I'll work you through
yours what do you wish should I do
I like I like this nunchucks over the
arm yeah yeah no no no you have to open
your body okay all right through the
arms it's too confusing while I hold my
thinness Ben all right I'll put on my
body a little bit well I think you chain
maybe you sleep you down man once take
this shirt off you gotta loosen up baby
girl do you want to see mine come in
[Music]
anyway uh you got the job you got the
job all right thanks clean yourself up
Newton shucks we were trapped in an
elevator today Jay and I are better men
and humans for it stronger were stronger
as a unit stronger as a group black Lou
you said you have bad experiences the
elevators before what else has happened
I went to Orlando were you escaping a
get out situation and you got stuck in
the elevator what a surgeon he was not
today man I went to Orlando you know for
a timeshare on a vacation bunch of
friends got really drunk and then the
timeshare we met some other guys that
had a timeshare and they had one of them
work for an elevator company okay he had
the elevator key which is like if you
ever see that little circle at the top
of the elevator and walk him you put
that in there and it kind of drops
down and you can kind of control the
elevator so we were kind of riding that
thing for a little bit we're just drunk
riding an elevator
drunk elevator rides yeah what
was the fun of the elevator ride there
goes dude you skip floors yeah oh it was
at first going like slow down no no no
shot up for like two floors I got into
space Willy Wonka style
he was like an emergency door on the top
of it or on our feet I guess and we all
started reaching for the door because we
didn't know if it was gonna stop and I
that was it wait so you were standing on
top of the other yeah yeah okay now
inside people get killed in that
situation all the time when it goes all
the way to the top yeah and like
squirts yeah yeah dude you would have
been a campfire story for three
kids you wanna drink your prom go ahead
but you know what happened right story
your black Lu my cousin got crushed
she's hanging out with white people on
the top of elevators crazy is why that
is that is some white dude babe you're
like you guys want to get on top of the
salad eh yeah I didn't realize where the
high school would rob dyrdek
yeah oh cool I didn't know you grew up
with John McClane
sorry I can't see so good is that Liam
Neeson over there come to Orlando ah
dude that's nuts Kristen who
else was trapped on an elevator someone
else Lin Lin was trapped Christine were
you me and Christine together on a
cruise ship yeah which is a little
scarier in a sense there's not a lot of
floors to be on your likes we do what
was scary what was scary is you believe
by what's happening outside the
elevators on a cruise ship on these one
these like the heavy metal ones yeah and
it was right I was one of the
rock-and-roll ones like no one who's
supposed to be handling elevator
emergencies is where they need to bid
you just assume that's just not the case
yeah that'll be solved quickly at all
but it was pretty quickly but I did get
that one I was Jake the doors open just
as I was about to get like alright I'll
panic too like I was starting to get
like Christine yeah I kind of just likes
it again so yeah we held it I mean no
one freaked out how long were you on
there for the same like like 10
minutes maybe it's just the initial
thing when no you're like am I gonna be
stuck in here forever hey so it's just
that initial panic of like that I don't
think it's supposed to stop I have no
idea I've no thought we're gonna be
stuck in there forever
I never feel that way what I do feel
like is that I'm maybe it's more
irrational my fear is especially of a
tie that's gonna like break and fall
yeah that's the thing it sounds like
terrifying yeah I wasn't scared because
we were on we're on the ground floor so
I really wasn't nervous at all Michael
get us out of here of it and they were
talking they were talking to us through
the door which he was I'm right here
with you do that which was the best
because they all of a sudden just come
over they go hi is anyone on the
elevator from NBC what a weird thing I
go we're all white all white inside and
then Jay said he was our Kelly I did say
I was our Kelly with a bunch of children
you got open this door and I drank a lot
of water I drink a lot of water yeah
yeah there she goes mr. Kelly we're
doing our house the best mr. Kelly we're
doing our best and then the crocodile
Hunter's wife
the door we got out that's it finally
able to get out Blaine you were trapped
to know that you said now here's the
thing
much like I don't want you don't like
finding out the reality of things yeah
because I was like I don't want to know
too much about airplanes I'm so afraid
of them already I'm in them constantly
you don't want the stats and I'm like
and look the idea is I always feel like
people invent planes or build planes
must build them so if all the mechanics
fail there's still some sense of being
able to glide a plane down to the ground
and then someone told me not too long
ago this that's not how plane where I
lean nosedive it'll go front and down
and smash the ground as fast as possible
like a missile and I go I just wanted to
think that I had an irrational fear of
that being the case yeah so the elevator
Rudy gruesome my go my fear of elevators
gonna break and fall down like but
that's a freefall doesn't happen in
elevators and then you told me quite the
contrary
I got stuck in one in an office building
downtown and there was a freefall that
felt like it went 15 floors it was
probably only like two but yeah been
around a little bit and I just kept
going up and down until finally landed
it was just freaking out when I got to
the lobby and like kind of like stumbled
out to the security desk and was like
you have to close the elevator they
would have opened the door to me furious
masturbating something else something
else happening in the world I just I try
to queue up a song to die do track in
your death am I going to die in an
elevator in a office building
and then goes got the playlist for this
I go well I'll go come in with some hurt
we'll move on to the time of your life
from Green Day and then we'll program a
little I did it my way take this job and
shove it maybe Alice in Chains rooster
this bad boy yeah they come to snuff the
rooster good camera
[Music]
we all try to pull it apart they saw it
happen in a movie we'll stop if I know
my diehards I think I can get to the top
of this we need one two three four five
six seven eight nine ten blankets yes
when they take us out we could all be
like we're victims or something terrible
okay it's good cryptic measures tell my
daughter to slap it up and keep it down
[Laughter]
your voice hey momma come down this
sir yes okay okay sir I
thought she was okay was my favorite
part
okay temperatures a little cold but I
might a little lonely and spacious out
here wish I had more people in smaller
quarters spread my mouth on a Dunkin
Donuts confidence she goes anyway I go
ahead I'm gonna go smoke a cigarette
I'll be right back sir what's happening
on the outside
on the floor of the 31st floor we said
we're good people we have like jewelry
made of like all kinds of cream just
like going native
this is our leader you call the Oviatt
again we could roast the bone in here
this guy's voice is so Union the guy
helping all right you guys you snuck in
there you guys a you guys are gonna
be mad about this one I was going to
yell at the doors open
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
that was the worst eight hours of my
life we're good praise that coffee is
not hot
5:50
I mean we got to open with the president
there's no why for whatever reason it's
so much less scary being trapped on a
floor like the ground floor of an
elevator that was really had no problems
with it I'm telling you because an
elevator is something that I'll stop
I'll stop
shall we stop our show content we go
right from farm to table I really didn't
like being locked in elevator the guy
just made fun of us assuming we were
gonna be out of the elevator I said I go
we shouldn't have literally a partner
who's your day Walker power because he
had his thing like this in the chamber
like this that was hilarious she goes
just blows everybody okay we go yeah
everybody just I'm okay all right what
the whoops excuse you guys I'm
gonna help you guys soon but currently I
am also trapped Oh elevator next year
what that's how that works let's go
we're running late
hey you should leave a comment below one
of us might be in a depression spiral
and read it yeah push us all the way
down yeah yeah yeah I can get pretty
dark gets weird so look forward to
reading it